your father has accomplished something  extraordinary also dangerous and the  only one who can stop it  is Hugh a warrior  it was really cool to go to IMS as a  filmmaker and to walk in there and to  just be talking to the great  craftspeople they're about extending and  expanding the image you know to be able  to see your image large the things that  you dream about and have crafted  super-sized because we saw it in my  little screening room and you know to  see it with real people and an IMAX is  going to be like  I think the visuals in this movie are  very spectacular big yeah yeah it's epic  and cosmic  the only thing faster than light  it's the darkness it's gonna blow my  head off is it amazing  [Music]